foreign
[Music]
we're playing three Love Is in the Air
three
Knight F3 okay nice so that is not a
move we have faced yet again my official
recommendation against D4 is the
grunfeld and I put some thought into
that decision
so you should think of the move Knight
F3 in the same it's it's in the same
category as D4 because it transposes so
often so whatever opening you play
against 1d4 a lot of people struggle
with this concept
with some exceptions you should play the
same thing against Knight F3 as you
would against D4 so if you're a gruntful
player you play Knight F6 G6 if you're a
queen's gamma decline player you play
Knight F3 D5
if you're a slav player you play Knight
F3 D5 and then C6
okay so whatever opening you play you
essentially play the same setup against
Knight F3 because it is so likely to
transpose into the D4 opening of course
Knight F3 could also be an independent
opening if white plays the king's Indian
attack but in this case we have indeed
transposed to one D4 and indeed we
respond with G6
which is the gateway to the grunfeld and
the King's Indian and after the game
I'll talk a little bit about why I'm
recommending the grunfels specifically
and not the king's Indian G3 our
opponent responds with What's called the
fianchetto setup surprisingly enough
and to start we complete the development
of our King side we go Castle short
and of course here we reach the main
Crossroads if you've watched my Blitz
Games in this position I mostly play the
move D6 which is what you play if you're
a king's Indian player
but if you're a grunfeld player and for
the purposes of this speedrun we are
grundfeld players we play the move D5
reaching a totally symmetrical position
our opponent responds with the main line
c2c4 and some idiot named Vladimir
kramnik played this against me with
white in a classical game
and uh I think I've even shown that game
on stream this is a very theoretical
line and I'm pretty impressed that our
opponent is going for a not a common
Occurrence at you know like 15 1600
level for players to go uh for the
fiancado grinfeld but still this allows
us to fill uh a gap in the speedrun thus
far
what do we do in this position another
major crossroads there are two main
moves the most popular move at a top
Grand Master Level is to play its slav
Style with C6 but the more exciting line
and the line that I think is more
testing at a club player level is the
move that I played against kramnik this
is not a bad move it's also very
theoretical but at least it leads to
some imbalance in the position we play D
takes C4 I'm way too bored uh to play C6
I think C6 leads to some incredibly
boring positions very often the position
remains symmetrical for a long time and
most games at the highest level end in
draws after C6 Knight A3 this is the
correct move by our opponent and here we
perform a very instructive procedure if
you aren't familiar with the theory of
this line it is hard to come up with the
next move independently does anybody
know what the move that I'm talking
about actually is
now the logic behind this move is here's
the thing we are not going to be able to
preserve the extra Pawn we can't play B5
because we give that pawn up
Bishop E6 is an attempt to cling to the
pawn but it runs into the very
unpleasant response Knight G5 and if you
visualize in your head Bishop B6 Knight
G5 you could try Bishop D5 there but
white counter strikes with E4
and then the bishop has to move again
and you've given up the entire Center
and you haven't even managed to to keep
your extra Pawn so what you often see is
a situation where you're already going
to lose the pun the pawn is condemned so
we might as well use this Pawn to
extract as much damage out of white
structure as possible so goes the logic
right if we're already losing the pawn
why don't we give that pawn up on our
own terms why don't we force white to at
least make some weaknesses in their
structure and that's where the move C4
C3 comes from
white has to play PC and you might say
well but doesn't that help white
solidify his central control on the one
hand yes but on the other hand the pawn
on C3 is now a backward pawn and of
course white is left with an isolated
opponent A2 but we can't fall asleep
here if we fall asleep we essentially
allow white to prepare E4 we need to
Counter Strike immediately we need to
grab our own share of the center before
it's too late and of course we do that
with a classic grunfeld move C5 leading
to what's called a tabia a position from
which there are five or six different
viable continuations the old main line
is 95. kramnik did play 95 against me
and in response in response to 95 black
is supposed to sacrifice upon I will
show you some of the theory after the
game
and there are some very very exciting
lines here this is actually a super
interesting line both positionally and
tactically and you should be able to
sense that like there's a lot going on
in the center
but if white doesn't play this in
principled fashion then our next move is
of course
very likely to be Knight to C6 putting
more pressure on D4
okay so it's it's a super complex
position
and I'm going to try to illustrate most
of Black's main ideas here as we make
our moves
can you go C5 before pushing C3 yes
absolutely so a completely viable
alternative is the immediate C5 but
after an I take C4 again the position
gets very symmetrical
and if we play C5 and then C takes D4
white recaptures with the Knight and we
want to be careful about a situation
where we allow the the fiancado bishop
to get too active right it's actually in
our favor for the Knight to remain on F3
because it for the time being kind of
cancels out the activity of the fionkyo
bishop allowing us to develop our Queen
side a little bit more easily
why can't white just take well if white
takes then he ruins permanently his
entire Queen side
and that also opens up our own
fianchetto Bishop in response to DC we
have many moves we can slide Our Queen
over to A5
forking two of White's pawns but we can
also play the move Knight F6 to E4
opening up a double attack on the C3
Pawn
and double attack in the sense that two
pieces are attacking it at once
and we don't mind a queen trade if white
trades Queens giving the D file be my
guest so one of the keys to
understanding the grunfeld is that you
almost never mind sacrificing Pawns
you have to be ready as early as move
four or five to give away the seep honor
to give away the epon right activity is
sacred in the grunfeld whatever you do
you have to make sure that your pieces
remain active
just like in all hyper modern openings
otherwise why are you giving up the
center right if you give up the center
and you play passively then you know you
should be playing the Queen's gamma
decline rookie one
okay that is a move it's not the main
line but it is quite popular these days
and I'm pretty impressed that our
opponent uh knows this amount of theory
now what is the purpose of rookie one
well the purpose is very obvious white
is preparing to play E4 but you should
understand that E4 is a double-sided
move on the one hand it occupies the
center with pawns but on the other hand
it leaves the D4 Pawn a little bit more
vulnerable and most importantly it
allows our light squared Bishop to
develop to G4 putting very significant
pressure on the Knight and therefore on
the D4 Pawn
so in these positions it's not all about
stopping your opponent from grabbing the
center sometimes you want to actually
encourage it so an instructive mistake
here would be to play Bishop F5 that
would be a little bit premature because
it leaves the B7 Pawn without a Defender
and white has a couple of nasty
responses like Queen B3 or like Knight
F3 to E5 so in this case we actually
want to proceed with our development we
go Knight C6
and we encourage white to play we
encourage white to play uh E4 sorry H3
okay so that's another very good move
our opponent is preventing us from
bringing our Bishop out to G4 now
there's a very well known trap in this
line
actually maybe it's not here no maybe H3
is inaccurate I'm trying to remember
let me think for a second
trying to remember something
so
there is a developing move that you
should be inclined to play if we're not
playing Bishop G4 and we're not for
obvious reasons what is the second best
Square for the bishop well the second
best square is of course F5 which
prevents the movie for and later on the
bishop can actually position itself on
e4 in order to cancel out White's most
active piece a very classic idea
but after Bishop G5 after Bishop F4
there is a well-known trick that you
have to be aware of white has this very
weird looking move D5
Bishop F5 D5 and hopefully you can
understand the idea if Knight takes D5
white Forks the two miners with E4
now that position is still not the end
of the story because the C3 Pawn hangs
and if we take C3 We're x-raying The
Rook in the corner so things get
incredibly complicated there and we
could potentially get three pawns for
the piece so that's the line I was
trying to work out
but Bishop F5 is far from Forced we have
a bunch of other ways that we could
apply pressure on White Center
and one other tempting option is for us
to play Queen to A5 putting pressure on
the Knight and flat out attacking the C3
Pawn
and the other good thing about moving
the queen away from d8 is that we're
vacating that square for the rook and
putting the Rook on d8 here should be
good for for obvious reasons
so I like the look of Queen A5 Bishop F5
leads to some very complicated tactical
complicated complications
let's play this in a somewhat more
conservative manner here let's go Queen
A5 I'm not really in the mood to allow
Bishop F5 D5 and we'll investigate it
after the game
let's go Queen A5
we're asking White
a rather annoying question right how are
you planning to defend the C3 Pawn
now a couple of tactical observations
and you can sense how complex the
position is and these types of
situations you really have to do the
work of making tactical observations
noticing things that could lead to
attacking and one such thing is an x-ray
that may appear insignificant The Queen
Is x-raying The Rook on E1 now who cares
about that well it's actually kind of
important if white plays the move Queen
D1 to B3 which is not unlikely then we
already have a tactic to exploit it as
long as the Rooks remain unconnected you
should always be looking at deflection
tactics what deflection tactic is
available after Queen B3 well you should
see it it's C takes D4 C takes D4 and
Knight takes D4 deflecting the Knight on
F3 and then capturing on E1 with check
and it's important that we capture with
check because otherwise the queen
potentially could get trapped there but
that gives us a Tempo to evacuate the
queen
okay so any move that leaves The Rook
anymore without a second Defender
uh is is a precursor to a deflection
tactic along this diagonal
of course we should also pay attention
to the Knight on A3 Bishop D2 would
blunder the knight in one move I think
White's best move
perhaps even lights only move is Bishop
C1 to B2
okay good stuff by our opponent
let's continue applying pressure on the
center
how are we going to put pressure on the
center well we already know
what technique is available for us to do
that we should probably play the move
Rook to d8 and something actually tells
me that Queen A5 might be an inaccuracy
if that's the case it's a very very
instructive moment because of how
tempting the move is
let me think
yeah Queen A5 might have been a mistake
because the movie should be two actually
helps white in the sense that it really
solidifies the center makes it harder
for us to put pressure on D4
but at this point we're in too deep
let's go rook d8 and that's a move we
should kind of just play automatically
and let's see what our opponent comes up
with here
yeah I don't think our opponent is
stream sniping I think Bishop B2 is an
easy move to find by process of
elimination they're literally just were
no other viable moves
all right so
let's not jump to conclusions
we are not afraid of night well Knight
C4 might be a good move here
Knight C4 might be a good move here but
you know we'll drop our Queen back to A6
or to B5 and I don't really see where
that Knight is is going to go
so position remains super complicated
and it's a battle over the center right
it's a classic grunfeld game where both
sides are jostling for position in the
center we are trying to cause White
Center to collapse and white is trying
to expand his central control and make
sure that all the bases are covered
essentially
yeah the movie four
is possible here
I'm not necessarily convinced that it's
the best move but it would definitely be
the principled move but if white wants
to play this position more
conservatively he can also play E3 and
really create a stronghold on D4
so lots of ways that white can handle
this position or white could do neither
and the move Queen B3
is a lot more appealing now that the
Rooks are going to be connected and
there are no more deflection tactics
along this diagonal
Queen C2 is our opponent's Choice all
right so let's unpack
this move again we already do not have
the deflection tactics because the Rooks
are connected so let's forget about that
I assume the point of Queen C2 is to get
out of the Rooks x-ray
and to prepare the movie for
now the the downside of the Queen's
positioning on C2 is that later on we
could try to get our other Rook to C8
and continue harassing the queen along
the semi-open files
so the very tempting move Bishop F5 runs
into E4 I assume this is our opponent's
main tactical idea Bishop F5 E4 and if
we play Knight takes C4 unfortunately
white plays Rook takes E4 and I don't
see any ways that we can apply pressure
on that Rook is going to be a situation
where white has two pieces for a rook
and we are going to be worse
what I want to do is position the bishop
on a somewhat less vulnerable Square so
that we could get our Rook to C8 ASAP
and another question that we should be
addressing here is at which point do we
take on D4 probably we should do that
sooner rather than later so that the C
file is open and so that Rook C8 comes
with greater effect
so I think the idea is crystallizing in
my mind here's what we're going to do
we can start with Bishop E6 or we can
start with C takes D4 but I don't see a
reason for us to keep the tension alive
I think we should just take on D4 and
get that task over with
and then after white recaptures we bring
our Bishop out to E6
which is not an ideal square but it's as
good a square as any it's the best that
we can do it's definitely better than
going Bishop to D7 that's a very awkward
move
another positive of the move Bishop E6
is that we are trying to keep the A3
Knight at Bay
and covering some of the queen side
squares that white could have otherwise
used
well Bishop E6 looks awkward to some of
you because it blocks the E7 pawn and
aesthetically you often are advised
against that but remember this is a
completely different opening we're
speaking a different language here and
at no point are we seriously
contemplating the move E5 that's
completely contrary to the spirit of the
position
so blocking the E7 Pawn is not a problem
well if white takes with the Knight of
course that's possible but then white
white leaves himself with two very weak
Queen side pawns and after Knight 64 we
would not have been obliged to recapture
on D4
let's go Bishop E6 so far I have to say
if white plays a couple more accurate
moves definitely black is going to be
worse and this just shows you that I'm
not a specialist in the grunfeld I think
I know it well enough to teach it in the
speed run but you know okay E4 our
opponent continues to to really impress
here but my idea is of course to meet
this move with Rook a to C8 this was
the whole concept here
and of course D5 looks like it wins a
piece but in response to D5 we can move
our Knight away and we will be attacking
the queen so D5 is a paper tiger
what I underestimated here is the
prospect of white just moving the queen
up to E2 I will admit that I missed the
move Queen E2 but our opponent goes in
very principled style D5
and now the tactics begin
so let's think about where we want to
move this Knight
where do we want to move this Knight
well we have two viable squares we can
play Knight C6 to D4
we we can play Knight to B4
but the downside of Knight to B4 is that
that Knight is going to be stuck after
white plays Queen B3
right and then white will be threatening
Knight C4 and I don't
not a big fan of that entire defensive
Construction
so the move that I'm inclined to play
here is Knight to D4 or Knight to E5
these are two very similar ones so let's
calculate Knight D4 what does white do a
white has to move the queen probably
he's going to move it to D3
then we probably have to take on F3 and
white responds with Queen takes F3 and
that's super nasty because then we
finally have to move our Bishop and
white can send the other Pawn down with
E5 and White's kind of rolling us off
the board
so we might have to bite the bullet and
play Knight B4 here
let's calculate Knight before Queen B3
Bishop back to D7 and what I like about
that approach is that E5 is no longer
possible because the pod on D5 is going
to hang
so given the constraints I feel like
night before might be the only move and
I think we should play it good job by
some of you you called it pretty quickly
I was skeptical about this move but by
process of elimination we have to do it
my process of elimination we kind of
have to do it it looks like I've already
played him once I wonder how that game
went because right now things are not
looking great
oh I played him yesterday
I literally just played him I I didn't
realize that
I played them in my pre well not in my
previous game but the game before the
last
it just didn't register
yeah yeah we played him very very
recently
okay
we gotta hang in there
yeah that was not an easy game either so
this guy is clearly just a super
underrated player
oh wait a second
I might have some good news I think I
see a really sexy idea
I think I see a really sexy idea
so
what what I'm noticing is that the
Bishops are staring at each other right
this is a relationship between the
Bishops the bishop on B2 is a type 2
undefended piece it's protected by only
one other piece the queen on B3 so a
tactic should start crystallizing in
your mind that essentially tries to
force the Queen off of B3 and that's the
move Knight F6 takes D5 which looks very
complicated but it's a very simple idea
if Knight takes D5 Ed then we play
Bishop takes D5 and the queen just has
no squares the only squares E3 but then
we recapture the bishop on B2 with
interest
so after Knight F takes D5 the problem
is why you can play Bishop takes G7
first but in that situation we don't
have to recapture on G7
what we can do is move the Knight away
from D5 discovering an attack on the
queen and then try to take the bishop on
G7 but it's not as simple as that
after Knight F takes D5 Bishop takes G7
let's say we play the move Knight to B6
white can drop the queen back down to B2
creating a connection between the queen
and the bishop but in that position I
think we have the move night before to
D3 and the queen has no squares along
that diagonal that it can move to so it
has to release the contact with the
bishop in the interest of time I'm just
gonna go for it my intuition is
suggesting that this is going to work
Knight F takes D5 might be a
game-changing idea
might be a game-changing idea
and this is a a pretty standard tactic
where you've got two pieces that are
facing each other and you know another
piece defense your opponent's piece and
you're trying to knock it off of its
square and this is why Queens are such a
liability on the defensive end because
anytime the queen is attacked it's the
second most powerful threat in chess of
course the most powerful is a check
because by rule you have to respond to
it but an attack on the queen is almost
as powerful as a check and that your
opponent becomes incredibly hamstrung
with with respect to what what he can do
right if you're not moving the queen
then you better be threatening Checkmate
or taking a bunch of pieces in return
but everybody watching should this
should make sense to everybody this
should not be a mysterious move
this should not be a mysterious move to
you
but the key is that after Bishop takes
Bishop we're not taking back on G7
because then white simply takes the
Knight
we take back and white just drops the
queen back and we no longer have the
attack on the bishop that was the
initial idea
after Bishop takes G7 we need to find
this intermediate move Knight back to B6
opening up an attack on the queen
and if the queen moves anywhere except
B2 then we can recapture the bishop we
are upon up the game is not over but
White's position starts to crumble there
Bishop takes G7 Knight B6 Queen B2 we
have Knight B4 to D3 that is a very
important move without which this
combination might have failed
yeah so after Bishop takes Bishop we
don't have to go Knight B6 we have
Alternatives we can even go Knight back
to F6 which might be the simpler move
Knight D5 to C3 is a very messy idea but
perhaps is even stronger Knight to C4
wow I'm impressed her phone have played
this I was apprehensive about this move
a little bit but I don't think it works
I don't think it works
I think we can respond to this move with
Rook takes Knight in fact I think we
have to play Rook takes Knight and there
isn't much thinking to do here because
otherwise the connection between the
bishop and the queen are is closed then
white will be able to take on D5 okay
Pawn takes D5
and by process of elimination I don't
like the look of Queen takes D5 because
that walks right into the X-ray
I think our only move well Knight takes
D5 blunters The Rook so it appears to me
that we have to take with the bishop
and that is quite an appealing option
actually because now we are the one the
ones setting up a potential discovered
attack on the queen
so it's time to take stock we're up two
Pawns
we're up two Pawns
but on the flip side our King is now
quite vulnerable because we've gotten
rid of our fianchetto Bishop and that's
never a good thing
and obviously our pieces on the queen
side are all kind of clustered together
and rather flimsy
so we've got the X-ray that's our
biggest asset but the downside of our
position is that the Rook on C4 is also
a vulnerability this bishop is not a
reliable Defender and the Knight on B4
is kind of neither here nor there so our
immediate priority here unless our
opponent blunders the queen
to some sort of discover check or
blunders a fork right so we're looking
for these types of ideas but more
generally we want to consolidate we want
to bring our pieces back very carefully
the ideal would be to bring them back
toward the center like Queen back to C7
Knight back to C6 and if we can play the
move E6 we really should consider that
in order to solidify the bishop because
the bishop is really the you know the
main Cog in the machine it's supporting
everything and we cannot afford to lose
that Bishop under bad circumstances
Queen B2 check
let's not go King f8 and get checkmated
in one move on h8 the priority here is
not to defend the E7 Pawn it's to keep
our King safe King G8
wow our opponent finding all of the
testing moves here Rook takes E7 now is
probably best for white
wow okay I'm
definitely met my match here let's think
yeah there is a pretty big problem here
and I'm trying to find a work a way to
work around
yeah this is exactly what I was afraid
of this type of scenario where white
develops a huge initiative in return for
the pawn
okay so I'm calculating the move Knight
to D3
white plays Queen F6 we play Queen to B6
and try to counter attack the F2 Pawn
I'm leaning toward the move Knight D3
but I'm really unsure honestly it's a
super risky move
okay
oh I have an interesting idea though I
think I found something very promising
here
so rather than going for the super risky
continuation
let's play the consolidating move Knight
back to C6 we need to get rid of the
stroke obviously the stroke is White's
strongest piece now originally I
rejected Knight C6 because it blunders
the pawn on B7 or it seems to but Rook
takes B7 walks into another x-ray
right so after Rook takes B7 I think we
have the discovered attack Knight to D4
and if Knight takes D4 we drop the
bishop back and take the rook and the
Knight on D4 is going to be hanging at
the end of the line both Rooks are going
to be attacking it otherwise white would
get two pieces for a rook and if we can
get the Rook to move back then we can
breathe a little bit easier we're up
upon the game will be far from over
but at the very least we can continue
working on consolidating our position
you can't keep track of all that well
let me repeat that line Rook takes B7
Knight C6 to D4 Knight takes D4 and we
just play Bishop takes back Bishop takes
B7 and all you need to see is that both
Rooks are combining to attack the D4
Knight
and the Knight is only one Defender the
queen
yeah probably assuming that Rook takes
B7 doesn't work unless I'm missing some
crazy tactical detail in that line which
is entirely possible
given how this game is gone
it's it's
possible that the best the white can do
here is to go probably rookie three the
classy move the Grand Master move is
Rook to E3 but that's not an easy move
for you know an intermediate player to
make because if you're moving The Rook
back I think the Instinct most players
have is to move it all the way back but
rookie 3 is a very classy move because
you're opening you're leaving the E1
Square for the other rook and White's
main source of counter play here is the
open e-file that he can use to try to
deliver a back rank mate
so Rook E3 is is would be an impressive
move I will have to pick up the food by
the way in like five minutes so probably
when this game finishes before we
analyze it I'll need to take like a one
minute break
let's please not accuse our opponent of
stream stamping there's zero grounds to
assume that he is
okay rookie three
our opponent our opponents are allowed
to find good moves okay that was a
pretty interesting timing though I will
confess all right rookie three
what do we do now
well we should probably do now
what we should probably do now is try to
trade Queens but that's much easier said
than done it's the problem
right it's much easier said than done
because if we go Queen B6
or even if we go Queen B4
White's Queen is the super annoying
Square on F6 but I have a very
interesting idea
I have a very interesting idea
I think we are going to go Queen B6
and we are going to politely suggest a
queen trade
now in the event of a queen trade we're
up a pawn and we're chilling if the
Queens get traded we have a free hand in
the end game
okay so it should make sense to
everybody why it is that I want to trade
Queens in the first place
I did miss Rook B3
so there's that
but probably the best move is Queen E5
yeah probably the best move here is
Queen E5 and of course the queen is
untouchable
okay Quinn F6 that was a little test
that was a little test
all right so our opponent goes for the
principled line
my idea here
okay let's get serious again because
this game is reaching it's like
climactic stage what was my idea in this
position well what I'm noticing is that
the Queens are again in an x-ray
and because they're in an x-ray you have
to consider Night Moves notice that the
queen defends The Rook so the move that
comes to mind is of course Knight to D4
and in the interest of time we gotta
Rush a little bit so let's play Knight
T4
so there's no Checkmate because the Rook
defends E8 the queen defends The Rook
and The Rook defends the Knight
so white cannot play Knight takes D4
because he blunders the queen I think
white has to go for the queen trade and
he does and here we need to be very
careful I think if we take the Knight on
F3 we lose because if you think about it
Knight takes F3 Bishop takes F3 a takes
B6 Rook to D1 pins the bishop and then
the other Rook goes to D3 we lose the
game
so we have to play a takes B6 very
important detail now white can still
play Rook D1
but we we are under no obligation in
that case to take on F3 with the Knight
we can take on F3 with the bishop and
the Knight on D4 is very safely
protected by both of our Rooks now the
position is objectively drawn there's no
question that the position is
objectively drawn if white plays this
carefully and makes a couple more
accurate moves white should be able to
hold the draw even down a pawn in a rook
end game but it's not the easiest thing
in the world to do it with the minute
so we will see how our opponent handles
the defensive task
but this has been a very impressive game
by white
so this has been this has been awesome
okay I'm gonna try to be as tricky as
possible
I'm gonna try to be as tricky as
I'm thinking about whether I want to
take or take on G2 first
let's take G2 first I'm going to try to
be as kg as I possibly can and now we're
going to take back with this Rook
now Black's General strategy to try to
win this end game is to double Rooks on
the second rank right because our Pawn
majority is hamstrung we have double
pawns so we can't really create a past
Pawn on the queen side we can try at
some point maybe maybe later in the game
to push the pawn up all the way to B3
but that's very far-fetched because
White's Rooks are very well placed so
that really leaves us with only one idea
the witch is to try to squeeze the Rooks
to the second Rank and essentially use
the attack on the F2 Pawn in order to
force white to play Rook F1 but man I'm
getting zero winning chances here
I think I've got one more chance
okay wait I have an idea
it just doesn't work
okay well go excuse you I mean there's
no choice I can't defend B7
all right I have an idea here
so here's what we're going to do
we're going to first and foremost Force
The Rook onto F1
yeah now we're gonna drop back to D6 and
try to force Rook to A1
but our opponent is is not falling for
anything at all let's go Rook A2 and now
he finally Falls for something Rook F6
now we have a little bit of an edge
finally we get a little break
finally we get a little break this still
our position is still not winning this
still should be a draw
but that was a serious Mistake by our
opponent serious Mistake by our opponent
and why is it a serious Mistake by our
opponent because we now have a double
attack
we are attacking F2 and white cannot
afford to give that pawn away if white
gives away F2 essentially the king gets
mated or I mean we will definitely have
great winning chances there
alternatively if white plays Rook B1 F1
then we drop our Rook back and take the
pawn
and then if the Rook goes back to B1
then we go back to A2 so we use the
attack on F2 in order to tie down
White's rook and we are going to emerge
with an extra Pawn here and with 40
seconds for white I think we'll be able
to squeeze out a win okay Rook F1 we
take the pawn and F4 great move actually
great move by white
now we can try to trade Rooks here but
I'm not convinced that The Rook trade is
in our favor
let me think
let's play the move H5 for now
let's play them of H5 for now and see
where it leads
why am I playing H5 well if you're
familiar with the Rook end games you
should know that this construction is
generally considered to be the best now
we're going to give a check on A2 and
force the king to make a decision
we are now going to go back to A3 and
cut the king off along the second rank
and now I think the last step in the
chain is for us to involve this rook and
put it on C6
and the idea is that we want to go Rook
C2 and we basically want to deliver
ladder a ladder Checkmate but apart from
the latter main we are also hunting for
White's Pawns still probably not winning
this is still probably not winning but
it's getting very very close
so we want Rook C2 but that's not our
only threat our other threat is actually
Rook C to C3
and we're starting to pick off the pawns
along the third rank so the moment our
opponent played F4 I noticed that the
pawn on G3 became a very serious
weakness and I tried to devise
ways in which we could
go after the pawn and the best way to go
after the pawn is to put two Rooks on
the third rank
so I think in practice this is already
borderline winning
I don't see a wave for Y2 to not only to
hold the pawns but also to avoid
checkmate 10 seconds see our opponent is
collapsing okay now this is a losing
move because we give a check on C2
and I think that's ooh
maybe that's not it okay we obviously
take
Rook B3 a great defensive idea by white
now we can trade but that might be a
draw so we can trade Rooks whenever we
want to here right there's no rush to
trade Rooks so what we should do instead
is double Rooks on the second Rank and
see where that leads I don't know
exactly where that leads but first of
all it's very easy for white to get
checkmated here like Rook G1 is an
attempting move in time pressure that
gets mated with Rook H2 so we could
squeeze this position out for a very
long time F5
good move
okay so taking on F5 is tempting but it
ruins our Pawn structure so I don't want
to do that and our second approach is to
keep as many pawns on the board as
possible because that raises the chance
that we're going to win one of our
opponent's pawns so the move G5 is
automatic F6
okay so this Pawn has now become a very
serious weakness how do we attack it
well we don't necessarily want to attack
it with our Rooks because we want to
make sure that our remain on the second
rank in order to be able to deliver
checkmate
so we need to employ our King our King
is standing on G8 and doing nothing it's
time for the king to do something let's
bring it to G6
sub JX
yeah this is starting to collapse right
Rook F3
well
we could most certainly go King G6
but then we have to be very careful
about why bringing the Rook down to B8
and starting to deliver a bunch of
lateral checks
so what I'd like to do instead
what I'd like to do instead
is to make a prophylactic move
and play because I'm not sure well Rook
trade is already winning for black
that's true Rook trade is definitely
winning for black but we're not in a
rush we can trade Rooks whenever we want
to okay it's very important to
understand that
so I like the look of Rook G to D2 in
order to prevent White's B1 Rook from
moving off of the first rank
on the other hand that might allow
no I think we should play Rook gd2
does that move make sense we're just
stopping white from going Rook B7 or
going Rook B8 the downside is that we
are yielding control of the G file so
what I had to calculate is the move Rook
to G3 which I think our opponent is
going to play
but then we bring our King up to G6 just
in time
and actually we're going to do that
anyway because our opponent is just
biting his time
okay again people are asking why not the
Rook Jade because we are trying to
improve our position to the maximum
before trading Rooks have we improved it
to the maximum I think we have and now I
think it's time to trade Rooks and win
the pawn on F6
how are we going to trade Rooks well
we're going to do it in the most
clinical possible way we're going to go
Rook to F2
there's a tactical way to force the Rook
trade which is a super important Concept
in Rook end games and I'll show that
after the game
okay we trade and finally we are getting
very close to winning the game I'm
getting nervous about my food which is
like sitting outside but let's finish
this off patiently
without losing any pawns King takes F6
for starters we are trying to keep our
Rook on the second Rank and to keep
White's King confined we need to defend
our Pawn so let's go H4
and the winning approach here is going
to be very straightforward as you'll see
probably why it's going to go King G1
we're going to keep our Rook on the
second rank
okay now one very effective approach
here is to understand that at some point
you can use your Rook to block a check
laterally
to block a check laterally
so for instance a good move here is to
play Rook to E2
wire Rook to E2 so that when we advance
our King up to F5 and white starts
giving us the side checks we can bring
our Rook down and block the side check
we don't just want to keep dancing with
our king forever we want to be able to
block the checks so that eventually we
could start advancing our Pawns
now there are multiple ways to win this
position to win this game
what I want you to understand is that
each individual move is not as important
as your overall strategy if you
demonstrate the right overall strategy
you're gonna win so you shouldn't be
asking why did I play King F5 and not
King E5 and the overall strategy is
obviously to set this Pawn in motion and
to create a pair of connected passers
which we are going to do
how are we going to do it well let's
start by playing F6 right
okay our opponent is waiting and now we
bring our Rook back to E4
and we do that in order to be able to
inch our King up to F4
now we could go rookie two but at this
point I think we should just take the
plunge and play F5
all right
King F2 okay now
let's start by playing Rook to B4 in
order to prepare to push the King off of
off to the first rank
now we are finally ready to play G4
and create a pair of connected passers
now this is a theoretical end game it is
not easy to win this if you do not know
the winning approach not easy at all
so embarrassingly I have not brushed up
on the winning approach in a long time
but I will do my best let's start by
huddling The Rook together with the King
again the same idea in order to be able
to block any of White's attempts at a
lateral check now we drop our King back
to G5
we are now ready to push the pawn up to
H3
the reason is that if the king inches up
to G3 we not get away with Rook to E3
check
okay and of course the the overall broad
approach here for black is just to
advance our pawns all the way until we
win okay now
now we have a bunch of things we can do
but the most efficient method is to give
a check on F3 and then to advance the
pawn one more time to G3 again I want
you to notice the placement of my Rook
why am I keeping it close so that if
white starts the lateral checks which I
think he's going to do we will be able
to block this check
eventually with our Rook for example we
could go King G4 Rook A4 check and then
Rook to F4 you want to avoid a scenario
where your king is just running around
the board and has and does not have the
ability to get the check blocked by The
Rook
okay
why it's going to try for a stalemate
but he's not going to achieve it this
game is basically over
and then we will be ready to play H2
check being very careful to avoid
stalemate of course Rook F4 blocking the
check laterally
and that's it we finally are ready to
deliver the last couple of moves now you
never want to play H2
unless you are ready to follow that move
up concretely but here we are ready to
follow it up and we use the same
technique as before if the king moves up
to G2 we force it away with our Rook
with the move Rock F2 check then we give
a check on the back Rank and finally we
promote to a queen with Checkmate wow
what a game 68 moves that was the
hardest spot Speed Run game I've had
thus far and it brings us to 1600 and uh
you know those watching on YouTube I did
play this guy a couple games ago that
was the Karo Khan game that was the
incredibly complicated Fantasy game so
clearly a very difficult opponent big
big kudos to our opponent for uh
uh for for holding on for this long and
making it incredibly difficult for me I
think I was worse out of the opening so
definitely a a lovely game I'm pretty
exhausted though I definitely need a
little break to eat thanks for hanging
out I'll see you later
[Music]